while peaceful protests continue across
the country some activists worried
vandals and looters will drown out their
message
each morning communities are coming
together to clean up the damage we're
now hearing from one activists in Los
Angeles who recorded the moment she
asked two vandals who appear to be white
to stop Vlad duthiers spoke with that
activists this confrontation between
protesters and vandals outside a
Starbucks in Los Angeles has been viewed
online more than a million times someone
black don't do that that's not what we
want we not gonna get anything done by
doing it how dare you add another target
to our backs we are out here because we
are targets right now courtney nicole
gardner recorded this moment in hopes
that others would see protesters
sticking up for their community not
tearing it down just described the gamut
of emotions that went through you when
you witnessed those two women and what
they were doing at that point I felt
that the media had been you know pushing
one narrative that you know black people
were out here messing up our own
neighborhoods yet again I understand how
the workers of that building the owners
I understand how they can be hurt by
that and it hurt me just miles from
where Gardner marched volunteers flooded
streets Tuesday to show the same love
for their communities we want to try and
go behind these movements clean up what
we can so that the good things remain
scenes like that played out across the
country from Minneapolis where George
Floyd lived to Denver to Kalamazoo
Michigan it was just an outpouring of
community support that you don't
experience every day in New York City
looting led to an outpouring of support
amid understanding in the Bronx these
people came out and they looted and they
ride it and that's unfortunate and we're
here to clean it up
but they are doing this in protest of
something that something horrible that
happened it's that message of empathy in
the wake of violence that Courtney
Nicole Gardner hopes history will
remember this is a protest for black
lives and if you want to protest on our
behalf which we appreciate hey please
come out here and do it in a way that
it's representative of what we are
wanting and asking for peace in our
interview Courtney Nicole echoed what
many of these peaceful demonstrators are
saying they welcome allies from every
race and ethnicity who support the
protest against police brutality
provided that they listen and offer to
help in a constructive rather than a
destructive way Anthony couldn't have
said it better Vlad thanks